we can get more now on the picture from
mario paul danny berg fled the city last
week and it's now in la viv john thank
you very much for your time here on sky
news this morning we're actually hoping
to speak to you at the top of the hour
but you of course have had to deal with
the delay because there was an air raid
siren going on and how common then has
this become for you in lev
hi everyone thank you for having me uh
actually comparing to mariupa um no
other city is that
horrific in ukraine so this air
sirens
um
they
sometimes they happen
just when something is
some rocket or plane is over and
sometimes it
hits with bombs like a couple of days
ago
with the
air
i think it was an
airport in in um
but as i said uh
i'm think i got so immune to any kind of
forming sound to any shelling or air
strikes
and when while people live in this
peaceful um
[Music]
peaceful
place that is not attacked
um heavily
they are
scared with sirens um
after mario but i actually
don't
don't even pay attention i slept when uh
the bomb last night was uh happened
difficulty
so yeah comparing to mariuper there is
no place like this now on earth um
[Music]
worse than mario
because there are no sirens anymore when
air airstrike when the airplane
comes to drop bombs there is no sirens
because the cities
cut off electricity
because of the air strikes and all power
stations don't work for two weeks now
um no sorry from the first of march each
month it's almost three weeks oh gosh no
electricity no heating no uh connection
or any network mobile network you have
this brick and it doesn't work and it's
useless
um and
no heating no water
no food food is running out and the fuel
and the medicine is almost
has always disappeared in the city
because no humanitarian it is allowed
inside the city it's surrounded and no
organization
is allowed out of the city
and under the constant shilling and
bombing and rockets and just every
10 minutes or every five minutes
people
just live there in helping to in
survival horror when i left mariupal it
was eighth day of uh invasion
um
it felt like the most brutal hell but
now what they do now what russians do
now is just
complete extermination of the whole city
of the civilians
although the city is defended by
militaries by our ukrainian militaries
by assad battalion by territorial
defense they are standing to the death
to defend the this city while all over
the russians and they are
most um the most scary things they are
coming from from the sky this guy hell
is coming from the sky to marijuana and
uh i
here in weave i help accommodate oh i
see my my beautiful theater
yeah this this is the this was the view
from my window actually
the drama theater it was very beautiful
and i still cannot say this the word was
sorry i'm still in this stage of denial
or
of course of course dinah and i can hear
it also
in your voice and as we were saying that
you fled mario paul last week and you're
just seeing these pictures these
pictures taken
some of them just yesterday and you also
mentioned the view from your window
looking onto the theater which has also
been shelled what are you feeling at the
moment when you look at these very
latest pictures that are coming out of
marielle paul
you know i found myself feeling
something very new something i never
ever felt before the feeling that i
cannot identify it's such a
strong mixture of something i never
uh
i never you know uh faced i think it's
like the hugest pain
the hugest hatred
um and the hugest
um
pride maybe even pride it's because of
nevertheless the city is standing and
it's ukrainian
yes it's just
being exterminated from the sky yes
80
of every of the building of
infrastructure is destroyed
yes uh
it is
it doesn't look like mario
who i know the why the way i knew it for
80 for last eight years
uh but uh it's such an interesting
mixture of
of pride and
upspirited
feeling but
with the huge pain and the very firing
hiatus to russians to those who
took my home for the second time because
i fled from daniels
um
eight years ago to settle down in
mariupa and to have my
new home which is now
just being exterminated not just taking
or not just occupied but just
exterminated because it was a symbol of
resistance for
uh the last eight years to from the 2014
from the beginning of this war
this city didn't uh let russia go
uh inside ukrainian tech take occupy the
bigger territories so i think it's
such a
um
such a revenge they are
having they just bomb
shelters from cultural institutions bomb
hospitals bomb civilian
uh residential
buildings all the time every minute and
it's
i just pray for those people
left behind although there are a
thousand a couple of thousand people
almost
20 000 people who at their own risks for
late days recently they managed to
escape with totally ruined cars
with a very risky dangerous road they
managed to escape yes yes
dinah i am so so sorry i have to
apologize because we've just run out of
time but i'd like to say a massive thank
you to you for taking the time out to
speak to us
i'm sending you all of the bests from
all of us here at sky news i just want
to say once again a massive thank you
dani berg in la viv there thank you
thank you